moving and shaking this morning is Apple  CEO Tim Cook according to Bloomberg's  new pay index you got to see this which  is the first daily ranking of the  nation's highest paid executives Cook  has the best pay for performance rating  of any CEO Cook was awarded 65 million  dollars in compensation last year  revenue has climbed sixty-nine percent  under his tenure to 183 billion dollars  his pay package also makes him that 17th  highest-paid us executive but guess  who's at number one on our pay index  it's that guy in the nude the surfer  dude GoPro CEO Nick Woodman he was  granted four and a half million  restricted stock units that were valued  at 284 million dollars at the end of  2014 go Nick